please explain what that is and why it's
important the boy defect is a very
common phenomenon in auto supply change
what it is about is the amplification
and a distortion of the main information
so as you observe in the market where
the man can fluctuate a small bit but as
every player in a supply chain makes
decisions based on forecasting inventory
control speculations all those
interactions resulted in demand for cars
and orders being amplified so as you go
up the supply chain you see much bigger
swings in orders compared with market
and why are they calling this the
bullwhip effect where here is a
graphical depiction of what a whip is
here I'm holding a bullwhip and it
should see the bullwhip has a long long
arm and as I crack the whip watch out
for my handle so the handle has only
moved 60 degrees while the tip of the
whip has moved more than 360 degrees and
that's exactly what happened
the market may have moved a tiny bit but
is it the demand information traveled up
the supply chain your upstream suppliers
may be seeing a much much bigger swing
and that is costly and that makes life
difficult for your suppliers because as
this portions happens so much bigger in
magnitude it makes it difficult for you
to plan production plan inventory
capacity planning transportation
planning and it's more costly as a
result
I
[Applause]
[Music]
we had the bullwhip in the class and you
know it's very I think engaging
something different for the students is
that generally you're approaching
teaching or teaching to me is an
extremely fun rewarding and productive
experience because when I teach I found
myself in ethically sharing my passion
of the subject with the students and
it's through those passions that
stimulated the classroom that motivated
the students to participate and the
participation and which the class
experience for everyone
myself included and I found that by that
passion and energy put into the
classroom the intellectual content will
come across much easier and the students
all contributed and participated as a
result and this becomes a cool learning
environment and that's the best way to
learn
can you talk about what you contributed
to broadening the field to a kind of a
broader holistic perspective in the
early days most people look at supply
chain as if this is about logistics is
about trucking about ships and
transportation warehousing but I think
today as a result of all these years of
research efforts by myself as well as my
colleague we have expanded supply chain
to includes channel marketing
information integration product design
design of processes accounting systems
economics in terms of incentives and so
this broadening of disciplines resulted
in supply chain being a
multidisciplinary research area
over your career how have you tried to
link theory and practice for instance
have you ever worked in industry
aside from academia supply chain
management is an area of research that
requires very tight collaborations and
integrations of theory and practice many
of the new ideas and inventions actually
happened in industry while petitioners
were pursuing new ways of running their
supply chain I emphasized very very
importantly the need to work closely
with industry starting with my first
sabbatical at Stanford when I went to
work at hewlett-packard as a full member
in their supply chain team trying to
understand what HP was experiencing in
their supply chain problems all the way
to the setup of the supply chain Forum
at Stanford which try to invite industry
members to collaborate exchange ideas
with academics as well as among each
other so this continuous interaction
between industry and academics is the
key for moving supply chain practice
forward
done a lot of work related to China and
China is now the world's biggest
manufacturer can you just talk a little
bit about the progress China has made in
improving supply chain management and
why why it's so important
China has traditionally been a very
major part of supply chain but the
contribution has been mostly in
manufacturing most people thought of
China as the factory of the world but in
recent years many companies have
recognized that China is also a market
China is also a source of innovation so
that when they develop products and
designs they can leverage the potential
power of many of these supply bases
because they are more than your
manufacturing partner that's why
Stanford has gone to China together with
Fudan University in Shanghai and the
sponsorship of Cisco to create the
supply chain Leadership Institute
the idea is to continuously train
executives in China so that they would
run their supply chain more than just
manufacturing but at the same time
allowing us to use that as the vehicle
to learn about the development in China
to partner with our Chinese institutions
to create new cases and new research
ideas because China is going to be a
source of the supply chain in
manufacturing in design in innovation
and ultimately as a market and how is
China progressing do you think its
supply chain management is improving
China has a lot to learn in terms of the
executives there they of course has been
an excellent manufacturing partner for
many many industries they have great
factories and they have great know how
in controlling cost and they are just
starting to learn how to integrate
themselves as part of a bigger supply
chain all the way from product
innovations design to the end
distribution and that end-to-end concept
is new to many people in China so that's
why I think they still have a way to go
but they recognize that and I think that
is definitely the direction while
multinationals also should recognize
that China is more than your
manufacturing
on earth and if that is the approach
that we take I think everybody would be
better off eventually it could be a
win-win for everyone
and why are emerging economies in
general so important in your work
emerging economies has become a very key
and integral part of my work because as
supply chains become more and more
globalized we are beginning to see many
of these new economies becoming part of
the supply chain of many many industries
they are a part of your supply sources
they are a part of your manufacturing
they're part of your assembly and in
some cases they are becoming part of
your market so we need to learn how to
integrate them and yet at the same time
this emerging economies some of them are
new some of them still do not have their
social responsibility structure in place
some of them also do not have as widget
laws on protecting the environment and
so as my research migrates to emerging
economies it's increasingly important
that we also capture the other aspects
of running an efficient and profitable
supply chain which is to look at the
environmentally and socially responsible
dimensions of supply chains what is the
future direction of your work as a
result of this globalization and the
need to look into emerging economies and
how to make them an integral part of the
global supply chain my future research
will Center significantly on how these
emerging economies can progress in the
business sense but at the same time
recognizing that we want to help to
preserve their environment we want to
help to make sure that they are socially
accountable and responsible to their
communities and companies that are
leveraging the economies there as part
of their supply chain also will pay
attention to the environment and the
social responsibility there so together
we're building a more sustainable world
a sustainable world that would be
extremely profitable and efficient in a
surprising sense but hopefully also
contribute to the sixth Ament of the
environment and that's my research goal
the next few years
you